you know the doggers live under one roof
they share a kitchen
which wow my hat's off to them they just
have figured out how to make it work
a lot of families can a lot of people do
even we're
contemplating what we want to build for
our final dream home
i want to design our house where we have
still a central kitchen that we all
share
but then each of these guys with their
own little kind of apartment and then
more some of
them joe wants and actually his bedroom
i want my own bedroom
so plural men never get their alone time
but plural women
do i think plural husbands
get jealous of the time that the plural
wives
have to themselves you want your own
bedroom i'm there
i'm like okay i am sick of going to
three closets
i'll never get that that'll never be
allowed yeah oh sure
i'm i'm tired of dealing with wives in
their closets and stuff like that blah
blah
blah you'll survive if i can survive
sharing you
and deliver the jealousy and the drama
and all the stuff that has to do with
plural marriage then you'll be okay
it's nice to see you man i think one of
our biggest problems
is we don't have other polygamists to
fellowship with
there is something there's a there's
almost a homey little safety
when we see you guys that just that just
like it makes me emotional it's like
seeing uh relatives
it's hard being away from other
polygamists it's so
it lives different yeah there's a
certain
cultural and just i don't know just
knowing people get it you know
yeah our family we're separating
and separating and it's almost like
we're interacting more with people who
are
not a plural family so they don't get it
so we're starting to react
more like
an individual family you know there was
a time
that we really pulled together and we
struggled together and i don't feel like
we're struggling together
right now we're struggling independently
of each other
it would be cool if it wasn't that way
we could really benefit from being with
other polygamists you know we've lived
in a monogamous world for so long
and it's hard it's hard
it's almost like we should move back or
something i don't know